Also in the detergent area, you always have to pass something,
which in itself is only
small because, if you like, every
detergent washes clean somehow,
but the provision of
special enzymes that specifically
nibble away these or those stains is
an added value every time. We now have
an innovation  brought onto the market
that also makes it possible to keep the washing machine
even cleaner when washing,
that the very smells that often
arise are microbiological
biofilms, okay,
which tend to form when
you no longer wash at such high temperatures so often
One or
two microorganisms are probably there and
in our new Persil we have now also
accommodated enzymatic options so that something like that does
n't form in the first place or if it
is there it is returned and
therefore no bad smells
arise